Margot Robbie, Emma Mackey, Margot Mackey,
Emma Robbie: You wouldn't be the first person
to get these two actors mixed up — and even
Barbie had something to say about their resemblance…before
the line got cut.
Some celebrities just really, really look
alike.
"I'm seeing double, here — four Krustys!"
Isla Fisher once put Amy Adams' face on her
own Christmas cards to see if anybody would notice.
Bryce Dallas Howard and Jessica Chastain apparently
spend inordinate amounts of time insisting
that they're not the same person.
And if you've ever watched Netflix's original
series Sex Education, you'll know that star
Emma Mackey, who plays Maeve, bears a striking
resemblance to Barbie star and Academy Award
nominee Margot Robbie.
In fact, it was their resemblance that led
to Mackey appearing in the Barbie movie, and
an early version of the film even acknowledged
their similar looks.
According to Robbie, this moment had to be
cut from the final product.
Speaking to Buzzfeed during one of their patented
"puppy interviews," Robbie said:
"She plays one of the Barbies in the movie,
pretty much because Greta [Gerwig] and I thought
it would be funny."
Gerwig and Robbie actually came up with a
joke about the pair's similar appearances,
but when all was said and done, it didn't
land the way they thought it would.
"We were going to do this whole joke about
us looking similar [...] and once we got all
dressed up as our Barbies, we were kind of
like, 'We don't actually look that similar.'"
As it turned out, the two actors don't look
all that similar when one is rocking blonde
hair and the other's a brunette.
"So we didn't put that joke in the movie.
But when people come up to me and say, 'I
loved you in Sex Education,' I just say thank you."
Maeve Wiley, Mackey's character on Sex Education,
changes up her hair color a lot throughout
the show, and it's worth acknowledging that,
as a blonde, she definitely resembles Robbie.
The joke clearly didn't land on the Barbie
set due to Mackey's natural hue, so it's probably
for the best that they didn't bother forcing
it.
Nevertheless, Mackey is a key part of the
final product as Physicist Barbie, one of
the residents of Barbieland with whom Robbie's
Stereotypical Barbie spends time throughout
the film.
In fact, Margot Robbie first met Emma Mackey
around the time they were both cast in Barbie.
So maybe it's not surprising that only after
the fact did they decide they didn't resemble
one another enough to joke about it.
Robbie briefly detailed what it was like working
with Mackey during a filmed interview for
SiriusXM's The Jess Cagle Show.
While discussing a prank of sorts Ryan Gosling
played on the rest of the cast during filming
of the movie's girl's night scene, Robbie
recounted feeling nostalgic about childhood
sleepovers while brushing her teeth in a mirror
alongside Mackey's Physicist Barbie.
"Then we shared a bed, and I was like, 'we
only met like two weeks ago.
We bonded so quickly, and I think the sleepover
had a little to do with it."
According to Robbie's Buzzfeed interview,
she and Greta Gerwig offered Mackey a part
in Barbie at least in part based on her famous
resemblance to Robbie.
Even though that didn't end up informing their
characters' relationship in the film, it seems
the two got along well on set all the same,
allowing Mackey to remain a part of its ensemble cast.